- I'm glowing, I might
not be Asian glowing,
but I'm glowing, from the inside out.
- I'm glowing from the outside.
(upbeat music)
- Hi, my name is Elton Keung
former owner of Boba 7,
aspiring owner of Labobatory.
And people are gonna try my alcoholic boba
for the first time today.
- I've always wanted
to try alcoholic boba.
- It sounds delicious, I think
it's going to be so great.
- I think this will be
a beautiful union.
- Same.
- [Elton] First drink they'll be trying
is the Green Tea Heineken
with Honey Green Tea,
Heineken and honey boba on the bottom.
- This looks delectable.
- This is fun already.
- Oh my God
- Ooooh!
- This is so good,
- Oooh, I love it.
- It just smells like beer to me.
- I always fall asleep when I drink,
so having green tea and caffeine,
I feel like it's a great idea.
- You actually don't taste
the beer after a while.
- That's like how tailgating is.
- There's always a weird
part where you're like,
sucking it up and then
get one (chocking sound)
(laughing)
No you don't.
Oh!
(laughing)
- [Elton] Second drink
is the Taro with Mezcal,
Mezcal is a smokey tequila.
- Oh wow.
- Ooh you can taste--
- Oh my God!
- The alcohol--
- It's so good!
- This innocent looking lilac, I was like,
that thing's gonna be a breeze,
and then I took that first sip,
and I was like no, there's
like a lot of alcohol
in there.
- This is like an X-rated milkshake.
- All of a sudden the alcohol just hit me.
- I already am like,
feeling it, I'm like wow
- I know!
- I'm happy!
- I'm like it's hot in here.
- If I need to describe
this as a pop star,
it's a Rihanna.
- [Elton] The Bobagasm,
which is a White Russian
with boba.
- Oh, oh (beep)
- Wow.
- Oooh, hummm.
- Asian butter beer is
the thing I didn't know
was missing from my life.
- Oh, so the boba has alcohol in it.
There is a God, and she loves us.
- This is my favorite one.
- It's like, the drink
that you wanna just curl up
on the, you know couch,
watch TV, watch some Netflix.
- I love how creamy it is, I don't think
I can drink regular boba anymore.
- That was like a spiritual
journey that I won't forget.
- That was amazing.
- That was a revolution for my mouth.
- Thank you guys for making these drinks.
- Come because--
(laughing)
a hug, thank you so much.
- To boba and alcohol.
(glass clinking)